viacom is in the business of
entertaining people lately though its
shareholders are anything but
entertained Sumner Redstone the ailing
media mogul who controls Viacom voting
shares and his daughter Shari have been
sparring with the people who run Viacom
it's become a bitter battle pitting the
Redstone's against CEO philippe de ma
and a number of board members some of
the same folks used to be part of the
moguls inner circle a spectator can only
presume that sherry is seizing control
of her 93 year old dad's empire pushing
out anyone who stands in her way
the drama is weighing on Viacom stock
price which had already taken a hit from
a string of disappointing quarterly
results about 20 billion dollars of
shareholder value has vanished in just
two years but while this has been a
corporate governance nightmare it could
end in a dream for shareholders there
have been reports that sherry wants to
recombine Viacom and CBS the other media
giant her father controls he had split
them up about a decade ago strategically
and financially and now makes sense to
put them back together let me explain
via comms networks aren't quite as
popular as they once were MTV has lost
nearly 300,000 viewers since a high in
2014 and it's a similar story for Comedy
Central the networks are struggling to
remain relevant as the industry moves
toward things like skinny bundle cable
packages and on-demand television via
comes ratings and ad sales are in
decline and its stock has fallen behind
competitors such as time order and Fox
CBS on the other hand is doing pretty
well and les Moonves the head of CBS is
considered a genius by the industry if
anyone can turn around Viacom it's
probably him a merger would restrain
--then the company's negotiating power
against pay TV providers that recently
underwent their own spate of mergers and
are deciding which channels are crucial
to viewers and which can be dropped from
certain offerings
a deal would also simplify Sumner
Redstone Empire before he passes making
the future a lot clearer for
shareholders who have had to endure
being left in the dark for months now